[Music]
earlier to find the area under the graph
of this function we found out the lower
sum that is in each sub-interval we took
the minimal y-values as the heights of
the rectangles and we saw that as the
number of sub intervals n tends to
infinity the lower sum approaches the
area under the graph but is there some
significance behind only considering the
minimum value in each sub interval why
do we take the heights of the rectangle
as the minimum Y values only in each sub
interval what do we take in the maximum
Y value would this work yes it would
let's quickly have a look
notice that in each subinterval the
value of y corresponding to the right
end value of x will be the maximum y
value taking these as the heights of the
rectangles we will get the sum of their
areas to be this take a moment to
understand this now notice that this sum
of areas is greater than the area under
the graph even if we increase the number
of subintervals this sum will always be
greater so this sum is called the upper
sum we denote it by putting a bar above
the symbol now we can simplify this like
we did earlier to get this expression
from this we can see that as n tends to
infinity the term 8 over n will approach
0 so we see that in this case also the
sum of the areas of the rectangles will
approach 16 therefore we get that the
height of the rectangles can be the
minimum Y values in each subinterval or
the maximum values in the first case we
get the lower sum and in the second we
get the upper sum and in the limit n
tends to infinity both the sums
approach the area under the graph
now there could be another important
question what if we take any y value in
between the maximum and the minimum in
each subinterval
will this also work yes it would
consider one particular subinterval
let's take any y value as the height of
the rectangle as this is the third
interval let's denote its area by a 3
then the area of this rectangle will be
less than the area of this rectangle and
it will be greater than the area of this
rectangle that is this area will always
be between these two areas this is true
for any sub interval so the sum of the
areas of these types of rectangles will
always be between the lower sum and the
upper sum but we know that as n tends to
infinity the lower sum and the upper sum
approach the area under the graph so the
sum of these areas will also approach
the area under the graph this tells us
that whatever y-value we take as the
height of the rectangles the limit of
the sum of areas of rectangles will
approach the area under the graph this
limit of the sum of areas of the
rectangles is called the integral of the
function in this case we will say that
the integral of the function between X
equal to 2 and 6 is 16 it's denoted like
this in the next part let's summarize
the whole process of integration and
understand what this means
consider this general function let's say
we want to find the area between X equal
to a and X equal to B that is the
integral of this function between X
equal to a and B we saw that this
integral is equal to the limit of the
sum of the areas of the rectangle in
particular we always consider the limit
of the lower sum and the upper sum so
what are the lower sum and the upper sum
right to find the lower sum and the
upper sum we first divide this interval
into n subintervals for the lower sum we
consider the minimum value of the
function in each sub interval and for
the upper sum we consider the maximum
value of the function in each sub
interval the rectangles formed
considering these values as the height
gives us the lower and the upper sums
look at this figure the lower sum is the
sum of the areas of these rectangles
symbolically we can write it like this
now look again the upper sum is the
areas of these rectangles symbolically
we can write this sum like this from
this we can see the origin of the term f
of x times DX in this symbol it denotes
the area of a rectangle but wait why do
we use DX here instead of Delta X this
is because we know that more the number
of sub intervals better is the
approximation as we increase the number
of sub intervals the width of the
rectangles becomes very very small so by
DX we mean that the width of the
rectangles is infinitesimal what we
really doing is adding the areas of very
very thin rectangles we see that in the
limit the number of sub intervals n
tends to infinity these sums approach
the area under the graph so the integral
is not the sum of the areas it's
the limit of the sums to signify this we
use the long s in this symbol instead of
the usual Sigma notation for summation
interesting isn't it
one last thing can you guess what the a
and the B written here mean correct it
tells us the value of x between which
the area under the graph is evaluated so
we see that this symbol tells us the
whole idea of integration with this
process we can find the area under the
graph of a function here's a function
for you can you find the integral of
this function between X equal to zero
and X equal to four share your thoughts
in the comment section below
remember we earlier said that the two
processes of integration and
differentiation are related to each
other now that we saw how to integrate a
function can you find this connection we
will see this connection in the upcoming
videos also didn't you find the whole
process of integration a bit lengthy and
cumbersome don't worry this isn't the
process we always use it was just for a
better understanding we will see that
this connection leads us to a better way
to find the integral of a function do
subscribe to our channel to stay updated
and to keep learning
you